a new poll out from USA Today and
Suffolk University shows Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis ahead of President
Trump for the 2024 GOP nomination and he
is not just up a little bit the poll
shows him up 23 points on the former
president in a hypothetical matchup
that's
56-23 now I am as skeptical of polls as
anybody I think that most of them are
made up and statistics are totally fake
but there are enough indicators at this
point to show that Rhonda Santos poses a
serious threat to Donald Trump's
perceived hegemony over the GOP Trump
obviously thinks so that's why he's been
attacking DeSantis and he started up
real attacks just before in the midterms
and DeSantis has managed to achieve this
status in a few different ways one he's
in office while Trump is out of office
so he can do things president Trump
can't really do things right now because
he's a Mar-A-Lago two
DeSantis is on social media Trump is not
on social media all he's on is the truth
platform that people don't really go to
other than to find his statements but
there is a third distinction that not
that many people are talking about but
that DeSantis is clearly hoping to ride
all the way to taking Trump's place
president Trump is the candidate of the
covid vaccine and Ron DeSantis wants to
make sure that you know that he is not
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Micah Shelby
who says a tweeted SBF didn't kill
himself right after I heard the story I
know it's really really sad that those
cameras outside of sbf's jail cell are
about to malfunction and the security
guards that were supposed to watch him
are just they're going to accidentally
take a nap and SPF you know he's he's
really been depressed ever since that
whole FTX exchange collapsed I mean he
probably would be you know if you lost
16 billion dollars and your weird hedge
fund sex cult in one day you probably
legitimately would be pretty pretty
depressed so too bad too bad that he
looks like he might get the Epstein
treatment and another Financial Guru and
sexual deviant apparently who was living
down in the Caribbean amazing history
repeats itself first is tragedy then as
farce
it's kind of farce both times actually
when you want to make sure that you've
got a super serious
set of personnel at your office you got
to check out ZipRecruiter right now head
on over to ziprecruiter.com Knowles many
businesses are hiring for festive jobs
this time of year like bilingual Santa
Claus coffee and nut gift basket
assembler and reindeer Wrangler those
are all actual jobs on ZipRecruiter
sound like a lot of fun too if zip
recruiter can fill those roles what
roles can't they fill if you're hiring
you should go to ziprecruiter.com
Knowles zip recruiter uses powerful
matching technology
they find and match the right candidates
up with your job you can easily review
those recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply additionally
zip recruiters complete Suite of tools
make it super easy to filter review and
rate your candidates four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
discover a hiring Joy with zip recruiter
go to my exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com Knowles kwels
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way
to hire
this is the key that a lot of people
don't talk about with DeSantis and I'm
not saying I am not saying that Trump
deserves all of the criticism about
kovid and that Ron DeSantis is
absolutely 100 clean on the covid issue
that's not exactly what I'm saying
what I am saying is in the public
perception
with
good reason I think
Trump is seen as the guy who gave fauci
a platform who promoted the vaccine that
seems to have some problems with it
again I don't know that any other
politician in Trump's place would have
done anything any differently or would
have performed any better I'm not I'm
just saying that's what happened
when Trump was in office
and Ron DeSantis although he was a
little bit cautious about covet at first
he reopened Florida really really
quickly and he has been ever more so
anti-coveted anti-public Health
establishment even anti-vaccine
so DeSantis who made the vaccines
available to people who wanted it in
Florida
but did not want to mandate the vaccine
he is now impaneling a grand jury
to look into the abuses from the vaccine
manufacturers Florida you know it is
against the law to mislead and to
misrepresent particularly when you're
talking about the efficacy of a drug we
see just the other uh just recently
Florida got 3.2 billion through legal
action against those responsible for the
opioid crisis and so it's not like this
is something that's unprecedented so
today I'm announcing a petition with the
Supreme Court of Florida to empanele a
Statewide grand jury to investigate any
and all wrongdoing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines and we
anticipate that we will get the approval
for that that will be something that
will be impaneled most likely in the
Tampa Bay area and that will come with
legal processes that will be able to get
more information and to bring legal
accountability for those who committed
misconduct Rhonda santis is a smart
smart guy I think this is the right
thing to do so I applaud him for doing
it but it's also politically probably
the single smartest thing that Ron
DeSantis can do because Donald Trump's
biggest weakness in a GOP Primary is not
actually his mouth or he says mean
things no people actually kind of get a
kick out of that it's not his Twitter
he's not on Twitter well he's on Twitter
he's just not using it now even after
Elon Musk took over
it's covid that's the weakness that's
the way that Ron DeSantis can position
himself to the right of Donald Trump
that's the way that Ron DeSantis can
counter the claims that he's a Squish
and a moderate the never Trump candidate
and and all of the criticisms that are
going to come along with him by virtue
of his place in the race and as the
candidate who isn't Donald Trump and uh
by virtue of the people that DeSantis is
attracting the never trumpers the the
Liberals and the squishes and he's
attracting those people and through no
fault of his own because he's not Donald
Trump and so he's got to figure out a
way to tell the conservatives and the
base no I'm I'm with you I'm a
conservative guy the covid vaccine issue
the fact that we were lied to about
safety of the vaccine we were lied to
about the efficacy of the vaccine we
were forced in most of the country to
take the vaccine if he can really go
after the people who peddled the vaccine
that's going to go a long way for
DeSantis speaking of those people
our old pal Dr fauci is back in the news
Dr fauci appeared on a Chris Wallace's
CNN show you didn't catch it I'm not
surprised nobody did I assume many more
people will see this clip on my show
then saw it on on Chris Wallace's show
on CNN but in that show Dr fauci
explained how difficult it was to work
for president Trump because Trump was
just such an irresponsible purveyor of
medical misinformation
what do you think of Donald Trump
well I don't want to get into the
politics of it
um so it is irrelevant what I think of
Donald Trump what do you think of him
from a public health standpoint well as
you know I had difficulty in that
administration because what was
happening is that it became very clear
that things were being said by the
president those around him which would
just not based on any scientific fact
and data in fact it was contrary to what
the data was showing and I you know I I
felt very uncomfortable about having to
publicly get up at the White House Press
Room and being put on the spot to
directly disagree with the president I
have such a great deal of respect for
the office of pregnant presidency that
it just made me very uncomfortable but I
had to do it Chris because I couldn't
stand there and be complicit in saying
hydroxychloroquine works when it doesn't
you know bleach works it doesn't and
that's how I evolved essentially in the
you know Public Enemy Number One of the
far right
that's all it is I I I heard the
president say that that we should use
bleach to get rid of covid-19 and I
couldn't stand there and allow that to
happen so I'm just a reasonable guy
except except
that never happened that never happened
I know that
most people the Liberals in this country
certainly and even many conservatives
believe that Donald Trump once said that
we should treat covid-19 with bleach
that did not happen that was just
completely made up it's a lie made up by
the media and promoted by Dr fauci here
is what Donald Trump said
supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous uh whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and I think you said that has him eject
but you're going to test it and then I
said supposing you brought the light
inside the body you can which you can do
either through the skin or
uh in some other way
and I think you said you're going to
test that too sounds interesting right
and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection inside or or almost a
cleaning because you see it gets in the
lungs and it does a tremendous number
along so it'll be interesting to check
that so that you're gonna have to use
medical doctors with but it sounds it
sounds interesting to me the new
headline is Trump asks people to go
outside that's dangerous here we go same
old group here we go simult group where
in there did Donald Trump talk about
bleach
Donald Trump said that there's a way to
use light to treat these viruses and
that you can do it by injection or you
can tell that he's sort of stumbling
around for for what he means by the
injection but he comes back to them the
light you know I'm telling people to go
outside I'm suggesting this UV light
kind of treatment he never says the word
bleach in fact even PolitiFact admits
that when Joe Biden says Donald Trump
told people to drink bleach and that
would make them safe from covet they
admit that's mostly false they said
that's not what Donald Trump was talking
about Donald Trump was did not
explicitly recommend ingesting a
disinfectant like bleach of course and
then they go and they they admit what
Donald Trump said right there that's
PolitiFact that's a left-wing
organization the whole thing was just
completely made up Donald Trump was
advocating a a very reasonable uh
medical intervention that actually
turned out to work very very well even a
Cedar Sinai admitted he had never used
the word bleach not even once he wasn't
referring to that it was it was a total
lie from the media that Dr fauci today
is still peddling
and he wonders why we don't believe him
the reason I bring up that whole story
one is because whenever doctors fauci's
in the news it's a good opportunity to
do my Dr fauci voice I miss him don't
you no I don't really miss him but but
two
it's got to get you thinking about other
news stories and it's got to get you
thinking about other genius experts in
the lab coats with the neckties
if they can make you believe not even
just make the Liberals believe if they
can make you a conservative sort of kind
of believe that Donald Trump talked
about injecting bleach to treat covid
they can get you to believe pretty much
anything
that had no basis in reality and even I
suspect most conservatives believed that
was true remember
when there was that line back in 2008
where the media said uh Sarah Palin
thinks that she can see Russia from her
house that was made up it was a joke it
was a joke from Saturday Night Live and
people attributed it to Sarah Palin
if they can get you to believe they can
get
not I'm not putting the emphasis here on
what they can get you to believe I'm
saying if they can get you to believe it
think about the sort of Trance
that the rest of the country is in
because of the lies of these very
powerful actors makes me want to curl up
into bed and when I curl up into bed you
know what I want I want to be next to my
wife wearing her nice cozy Pajamagram
right now go to pajamagram.com tell them
that Michael sent you women love getting
new pajamas at Christmas time Pajamagram
makes it super easy for us men this year
I cannot wait to see sweet little Elisa
wearing a set of pajamas from their
naturally nude line
even more alluring than lingerie the
texture and feel of these pajamas is so
silky and smooth that both you and your
wife will love them if you have no idea
what to get your girlfriend or wife this
year trust me she wants these pajamas
but you need to order today because last
year they sold out before Christmas I
actually got caught one year I wanted to
get them and they were sold out before
Christmas it was very very frustrating
so don't let that be you order today and
Pajamagram will include a free matching
naturally nude nighty with your order
that is 75 savings on their best-selling
holiday gift pajama gram offers free
gift packaging so your present comes
ready to put under the tree go to
pajamagram.com right now and order the
naturally nude pajamas that is
pajamagram.com for naturally nude
pajamas don't forget to tell them
Michael sent you everybody's blaming
Trump it's Trump's fault for everything
Mitch McConnell is just just asked about
why the Republicans did so poorly in the
midterms now that now that not only is
election day over but the special
election the runoff in in Georgia is
over and who does McConnell blame he
blames Trump we ended up having a
candidate quality time anybody remember
who mentioned that back in August look
at Arizona
look at New Hampshire and a challenging
situation in Georgia as well
we did by we I mean the Senate
leadership fund did intervene in two
primaries in Alabama and in Missouri
and I do think we had an opportunity to
relearn one more time
security you have to have quality
candidates to win competitive Center
races
went through this in 2010
2012. Christian O'Donnell Sharon angle
Todd Aiken Richard Murdock and
unfortunately Revisited that situation
in
2022.
our ability to control the primary
outcome was quite Limited in 22 because
of the support of the former president
proved to be very decisive in these
primaries
did you catch that
no not the blaming Trump
no not the candidate quality thing which
to me is quite overstated in a year
where John Federman was sent to the U.S
Senate I don't really want to hear about
candidate quality I think there were
probably some other issues at play they
ran a man who couldn't speak and didn't
show up on the campaign Trail and had a
radical insane record and wanted to shut
down fracking in an important Rust Belt
State and who wanted to let the
murderers out of prison as his first
priority so I don't want to hear about
candidate quality okay I think that's
really overstated but that's not the
part I'm directing your attention to did
you hear the part
where cocaine Mitch said that he had a
little bit of trouble controlling the
primary outcomes
I thought I thought the whole purpose of
the primary was so that the people have
their voice heard and they picked their
nominee and then the nominee goes on and
faces the Democrat
who who is controlling the primary
outcomes
this is where we're out all over
throttle control and prior outcome
because of the presence of the horrible
president of the rise
so it's Trump's fault
because he he backed some of the wrong
candidates and he did not allow the GOP
leadership to pick the primary outcomes
but the GOP that the Republicans are
supposed to be largely hands off in the
primaries you're supposed to let the
Republicans at the local level decide
this sort of thing that's not how it
works
that's not how it works at all
they want they want to control the
primaries they don't want conservatives
really to have a choice
and Mitch McConnell says logos and I
want to control that so that we have
good candidates who can beat the
Democrats yeah fine I I get it I want
good candidates too
but I don't want just some squish
I don't want to send some democrat to
Washington with a red tie on
and I'm not convinced I'm not convinced
for one second that candidate quality is
the reason that the races didn't turn
out well in Arizona which was bedeviled
by election shenanigans
I I'm not convinced that
election or candidate quality rather was
totally the problem elsewhere in the
country either
we need to control the party okay well
speaking of control the conservatives
now are trying to take back a little bit
of control at least in the house uh
Kevin McCarthy
is a moderate sort of establishment type
in house leadership he probably will be
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives but he is facing a
challenge challenge will come from Andy
Biggs uh Republican congressman from
Arizona he is running against Kevin
McCarthy uh McCarthy won the Republican
nomination to become speakers they've
already had that
he beat Biggs by a vote of 188 to 31.
Biggs though says that he is going to uh
run anyway in the main race so it could
be very very interesting to to see
because the Republicans will have a
razor-thin majority it will be
interesting to see if biggs's presence
will upset the numbers enough that who
knows you could have maybe you could
have a Democrat coming together with
some Republicans to try to win the
speakership it remains to be seen but
the reason Biggs is doing this Biggs
runs the house Freedom caucus is he says
that McCarthy's leadership as Speaker of
the House
would entrench the establishment
uniparty in Congress
the sense that the Republicans don't
really
do very much at all maybe they they yell
and they scream and they make a big
noise about about what they're doing but
when push comes to shove it the really
crucial matter is they squish
that remains to be seen if Biggs can
convince enough people to come on over
to that side but but you you are seeing
right now I think this is what a lot of
the anti-trump rhetoric is about the
establishment squishy lib side of the
GOP was cast into the outer darkness in
2016 and they were Furious and they
hated that Trump was the nominee and
they hated that he won the presidency in
in
some cases
and they were just so so angry to be out
of power and they now see this as their
opportunity finally to get rid of trump
and so DeSantis is looking great right
now and that might be the end of the
story it might the end of the story
might be that Trump had his moment and
now he's going to fade away and younger
politicians are going to rise up and in
the form of Ron DeSantis or somebody
else that could be the end of the story
but I suspect a lot of the lingering
support for Donald Trump and I feel it
within myself a lot of it is because
all the right people hate Trump and so
it's not really even about this policy
or that policy or this politician was
better on this issue or this guy was
it's not it's just it's just this gut
sense which I think is justifiable that
all the right people
hate Donald Trump and all the right
people love Trump's opponents or willing
to support Trump's opponents and and
that that does tell you something
whether that is enough to push Trump
over the edge
not so sure but it does tell you
something about what Trump represents in
American politics
people are are trying to take things
into their own hands and throw off the
settled established political
establishment speaking of taking things
into one of one's own hands Amazing
Story just saw it today
a Nevada woman
was attending a party
she and a friend pull up outside the
house that this party's going to take
place at I guess they got there a little
bit early so they're sitting in the car
and as they're waiting two men with guns
come up and throw them out of the car
and and try to steal the car it's it's a
carjacking so one of the men grabs this
lady's shirt pulls her out of the car
gets into the car and he puts his gun
down on his lap I guess while he's
starting the car putting it into gear
while he does that the woman takes the
gun and runs off with it
at this point the man trying to steal
the car starts running after her tackles
her at which point she puts a bullet in
his head and the man stops attacking her
because he doesn't have a head anymore
and I read this story and a lot of
people read that they say oh it's always
nice when stories have a happy ending
and this does have a relatively happy
ending in the sense that the innocent
party was not killed there was Justice
Done the woman defended herself and it's
not even like she ran away and then took
aim and fired at him he was continuing
to attack her so she was totally
justified obviously but it's always sad
crime is sad I feel sorry for criminals
in the way I feel sorry for a sick
person because it's just they're just
not doing the right thing and they're
harming others and themselves in their
own Immortal Souls
but the reason the story struck me is
why did this guy chase the woman
this guy was lucky to get away with his
life she ran away he could have just
taken the car
but no he got out and chased her to get
his gun back
and then tackled her she's got a gun and
he thinks she just doesn't know how to
use a gun and then his head gets blown
off
because the woman's got a gun why this
guy must have felt so confident that
nobody would stop him from doing bad
things and this is what happens when the
political order spirals out of control
much of politics is about managing
social expectations
the Second Amendment exists not
because of some high-minded Philosophy
from the enlightenment in America not
because uh people want to go hunting or
something like that not because that's
not the primary
purpose or political effect of the
Second Amendment
the primary purpose and political effect
of the Second Amendment is to keep
people polite
to keep the government polite and to
keep your neighbors polite to keep you
polite because if you were walking
around in a country where people can
defend themselves
you're going to be less inclined to try
to take advantage of people
okay if you're walking around in a
country where there's strong Law and
Order you're going to be less inclined
to commit crimes because you know you're
going to get caught you're going to pay
the price and what has happened is as
our political order has unraveled you've
seen a complete resetting of people's
expectations
and and that that is tragic for
everybody
it's tragic for victims it's tragic for
the criminals too because these
criminals are emboldened to engage in
this risky insane sort of behavior and
the end of that is going to be them
getting their heads blown off
in in a lot of cases the end of that is
going to be our society getting its head
blown off if we don't get serious again
okay
so call your friends talk to your
friends make sure that you're
politically organized when you want to
talk to your friends you got to check
out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles are you
tired of overpaying for your wireless
network get talk text and blazing fast
data for just thirty dollars a month
Pure Talk gives you the same network the
same towers and the same coverage as the
other guys at half the price Merry
Christmas everyone pure talks us-based
customer service team makes the switch
incredibly easy you can feel good
knowing that you're supporting a
veteran-owned business
here's the best part when you go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles you will
save an additional 50 off your first
month there is no reason to pay Verizon
ATT and T-Mobile over 80 a month for
wireless Services when you get the same
service on the same network at Pure Talk
for half the price go to Pure talk.com
enter code Knowles Canada wlas to save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles for 50
off your first month Pure Talk simply
smarter wireless head on over right now
I really love these guys saving me a ton
of money I think you are going to love
them too and you get the same great
Network same great stuff right now promo
code knows 50 off your first month at
puretalk.com
speaking of firearms there was a major
bomb
at movie theaters over the weekend this
would be a movie called to the end it is
a documentary about climate change
featuring Alexandria ocasio-cortez this
movie opened in 120 theaters
do you know how much money the movie
brought in
the movie I've never seen members like
this before I've been in Hollywood I've
worked in the media for a long time
120 theaters had the movie the movie
brought in nine
thousand six hundred sixty seven dollars
that is that is no money
it brought in statistically zero money
this was directed by a woman named
Rachel lears
Rachel lears's previous movie uh was on
Netflix it's called knock down the house
it also featured AOC and the way you
knew this movie was a real doozy is if
you go to Rotten Tomatoes to look at
that movie
uh her previous movie had a Critic score
of 99 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes and an audience score
of 11 percent
so
if if you're especially if you're
talking about political content when a
movie has a high critic score that's
usually a bad sign when a movie has a
low audience score that's usually a bad
sign and when the Delta between the
critics and the audience score is very
very great you know that you have got
just a Primo piece of democrat
propaganda so for this movie the climate
change movie to the end the critic score
is 83 so it's much lower than her
previous AOC movie and as I showed you
man even the critics couldn't totally
get behind this one and there is no
audience score
because no one saw it so there aren't
aren't enough people reviews audience
reviews to to figure that out there's no
appetite for this stuff which is very
encouraging because if you just read the
New York Times and watched CNN and
listened to your teachers in your
liberal schools and listen to the
government you would believe that people
were truly
on the edge of their seats waiting for
the nuclear
well not nuclear I guess solar
apocalypse waiting for the environmental
disaster the world's going to end in
five years we're also but no one cares
No One Believes it nobody cares it is
contrived it is a lie that we are being
told
it's a bill of goods that we were being
told I'm not even saying it's a bill of
goods about the environment stuff I mean
I don't even know what the story is
about the environment they said that the
world was Cooling and we were headed for
an ice age and all the top scientists
said it and all the media said it and
they said it was warming and we were
going to all go extinct really soon and
then then they said it's just kind of
doing stuff it's just it's changing
that's going to kill us and they keep
pushing forward the date of when the
world is going to end and so I don't
even know what what the thesis is but
the bill of goods that they are selling
us
is that this is a top issue this is not
a top issue for anybody nobody actually
cares don't be put in that trance okay
they can convince you you who watched
the clip of Donald Trump
you watched him not tell people to
inject themselves with bleach and they
convinced you that he told you to inject
yourself with bleach they can they put
you in a trance it's a form of hypnosis
do not let them do that on these other
issues do not let them do that on
climate change or anything else
so real it's a real art
this art of deception speaking of the
art of deception
it's going to be one of my best
transitions ever a daily wire is just
breaking some news now we've had an
investigator investigative reporter Bree
Dale on this story for a while now and
it's a it's a really quirky strange
story a one one attorney is describing
this the story as a high-tech Heist and
the broads drugs I encourage you to go
to dailywire.com and read the story
the broad Strokes of it are that people
are stealing they seem to be stealing
the Priceless art from the Vatican
without taking the physical art they're
doing it it would seem
through these corrupt kind of Licensing
deals such that here's how I'll explain
it if I were to put a book together of
all that beautiful art that's that's
owned by the Vatican right now I would
have to license the art from the Vatican
we're from some intermediary company
between me and the Vatican there was a
company that that wanted to
print some photos of the Vatican art
they go and and they see that the
Vatican art was was listed in this book
and so they they contracted this company
that put out the book it's called
scripta moneyonde
and said okay how do we get the rights
to these these pictures and they said
okay well you've got to do it with this
collaboration that we've got with the
Vatican Museums director Monsignor Paulo
nicolini and so scripta said here don't
worry here's how we'll take care of it
just send us 550 000 and then uh send a
Cash Wire in the amount of eighty two
thousand five hundred dollars cash wire
and then we'll be able to get you this
art
now
what our reporters seem to uncover is
that some of this money
looked like it was going directly to the
Monsignor well that's kind of weird and
the Vatican didn't seem to to know that
this was being licensed out and so
anyway it's a whole convoluted story
give it a read I find this sort of thing
very very fascinating because
something somewhere here doesn't make a
lot of sense it would seem to be
some kind of financial corruption
somewhere or gross incompetence but
people are making hundreds and thousands
of dollars probably millions of dollars
off of art that is owned by the Vatican
the Vatican doesn't really seem to be
getting that money it doesn't really
seem to care that it's not and it just
the reason I bring up that story other
than it's kind of an interesting
investigative piece of daily wire the
daily wire uncovered
is to show you how the corruption works
corruption use the Catholic Church as an
example the Catholic Church
scandals
in recent years
what are the scandals it's the sex
scandals of course and they're very
scandalous there's no doubt about that
but when you look into the actual abuse
that the Catholic Church
Bank members of the clergy engaged in
you will notice that the Catholic sex
abuse Scandal is no worse no no uh more
widespread in terms of its numbers
then sex abuse among any other religious
group
and so you remember the Southern Baptist
convention had a big one just a few
years ago big
sex abuse Scandal there have been sex
abuse scandals in the Hasidic Community
they're just in every religious group
through these scandals
furthermore
sex abuse in the Catholic church is much
less prevalent than sex abuse in public
schools so so these edgy atheists and
leftists and secularists they always
want to make snickering jokes about
those pedo priests those little child
diddling priests and they're well okay
if you're going to make those jokes you
should make those jokes much more
frequently about public school teachers
people will be very offended they'll say
that's that's a horrible thing to say no
there are plenty of great Public School
teachers plenty of priests the vast
majority of them
doesn't downplay the abuse people really
have been abused by priests and teachers
and everything but it's just so that's
what people focus on right
the much more widespread source of
corruption these subtle little things a
guy maybe paid off this guy and it was
some cash under the table and you better
there was a there was a trend I noticed
in recent years of whenever any anyone
started to look into the Vatican bank
and some of the corruption that was
going on at the Vatican Bank those
people would always find themselves on
the outs maybe they'd get accused of sex
abuse maybe they'd be accused of
something else but it was very hard to
look into the corruption of the Vatican
bank that's the kind of subtle
corruption that you see here is a great
example of this
the New York Times
we know New York Times is corrupt we
know the Press is corrupt but they're
not just corrupt on the big ticket
sensationalists top headline items it's
all the little stuff New York Times just
ran a piece on the most stylish people
in the country and do you know who made
the list
John Federman
John fetterman the senator elect from
Pennsylvania this man who is not I don't
want to be mean and sort of make fun of
his appearance but he's
you know he's a he's kind of a big he's
an interesting looking guy and when we
talk about his style
the man you know is not a Gucci model
okay the guy wears big oversized hoodies
and gym shorts and he's generally kind
of unkempt and he can wear running shoes
and he's not
he's not Marcelo mastriani okay
so why did the New York Times say that
he's an icon of style do you think he's
very stylish no
does the New York Times think he's
stylish no
does John fetterman think that he's
stylish no
nobody does
that's why
they are dead set
I'm telling you
that John Federman is stylish because
they are dead set on transgressing and
subverting everything that you believe
everything that you know to be true it's
a power play if they can tell you is
this the end of 1984 I know it's an
overused example but too bad if they can
tell you
to say that 2 plus 2 equals five and
they can make you say that and you they
can make you even believe that in some
cases
then they have total power over you
they're not they're not listing John
fetterman in their stylish collection of
people despite his lack of style and
fashion they're doing it because of his
lack of style and fashion they're doing
it because they know it's a lie they're
doing it because they call good evil and
evil good and Truth falsehood and
falsehood truth and they call Beautiful
images and fashion and art
ugly and ugly images and fashion and art
beautiful they're so dishonest they just
did the Washington Post just just had a
similar sort of attack they came out
and they were describing the Twitter
files releases which they are doing
their best to downplay and it's why I
think Elon Musk is releasing it so
slowly and so consistently is so that
they can't that the the media can't just
come out and shut the whole thing down
and say oh it's nothing Look Away
nothing to see here but he keeps it in
the news and despite them saying it's a
nothing Burger nothing to see here move
on move on so Washington Post comes out
and they say
uh they're talking about Joel Roth
former head of safety and and trust and
they say his Communications with other
Twitter officials have been posted in
recent days as part of what musk calls
the Twitter files a series of tweets by
conservative journalists Matt taibi and
Barry Weiss
so they're trying to downplay excellent
journalism much better journalism than
anything The Washington Post has put out
they're trying to downplay the the
journalism by taibi and Barry Weiss
but the most insane part of that is they
call them conservative journalists
Matt taibi is an atheist former
contributing Editor to Rolling Stone
Barry Weiss is a lesbian former staff
editor at the op-ed page of the New York
Times and a bunch of other liberal
places
I like their work I mean obviously
they're doing very good work on the
Twitter files and I like some of their
other work as well
if those two people are conservatives I
don't know what conservative means
they're obviously not conservatives all
all that is meant by conservative now as
the Washington Post and lives using it
it's just people we don't like that's
what they're they're saying the Twitter
files a series of tweets by people that
we don't like Matt taibi and Barry Weiss
that's all it means that's it you're all
conservatives now this is how Bill Maher
and Joe Rogan and all the rest of these
guys have and Elon Musk for that matter
have become conservatives none of these
people are particularly conservative all
of these people voted for Barack Obama
all of these people by any any
reasonable measure would be on the left
but the the because of the dishonesty of
the media
because because of the dishonesty of the
media many of them have moved further to
the right and because of the dishonesty
of the media people will refer to them
as being on the right now I'm imploring
you do not miss out on our last daily
wire backstage of the year that would be
tonight seven six o'clock Central
from the red wave that was not to Elon
dropping the Twitter files the rest of
the gang and I will be discussing the
most important stories of the day and
the year witness the festivities and
join me then Matt drone the god king
Jeremy boring for a very merry backstage
you do not want to miss it so tune in
tonight 76 Central
dailywireplus.com we will see you there
speaking of definitions the Cambridge
Dictionary
sort of the younger
stepbrother of the Oxford dictionary no
one ever cites the Cambridge Dictionary
it's always the Oxford English
Dictionary but anyway the Cambridge
Dictionary has just updated its
definition of woman
here we go you know I think we all know
okay here let's say a definition
their their definition of woman now
includes as one of those subsets
an adult who lives and identifies as
female though they have been said to
have a different sex at Birth
first problem with this who's they
you're talking about a single individual
but now you're using they
but the Oxford English Dictionary tells
me that he is the single gender neutral
pronoun so they're already you see the
transgenderism in the definition
before they say anything about what a
woman it's just the use of they does
that
and they say what's a woman a woman is
an adult who lives and identifies as
female
though they may have been said
to have a different sex at Birth Marion
Webster did something differently
Merriam-Webster says a woman can be
someone who has a gender identity that
is the opposite of male so it could be a
man but as long as his gender identity
is the opposite of male he's a woman so
what do we do about this
the conservative response to date
to the people changing all the
definitions is what it's to pull out our
definitions so okay according to the
2022 dictionary a woman means a man who
thinks he's a woman but well I've got my
dictionary from 1992. or 2002 or even
2012 and that dictionary says that a man
is not a woman
or whatever and then we keep we have all
these debates so remember my dictionary
says this well but my dictionary says
that and it is the
the recourse in argument of a child this
is the sort of thing
that you do when you're a freshman in
college and you're having a bowl session
late at night and you're arguing over
some big question
and and you just try to be as pedantic
as possible and you pull up some line
well in this textbook it's who cares
that doesn't tell me a woman is not a
woman because it says so in the
dictionary
dictionaries can be helpful they're one
piece of evidence to but that's not I
mean I've gone back and said this many
times when we talk about transgenderism
because the other strategy we have when
we talk about transgenderism is what we
say well a woman is
whatever biology says about a woman a
woman is two x chromosomes that and
that's a woman and if you don't have two
X chromosomes you're not a woman that's
not all a woman is
that presumes that the physical world is
the fundamental grounding of reality and
we know that that's not true the
metaphysical World certainly has
something to say about reality too my
soul has something to say about my
reality doesn't it what is a woman every
dictionary in the world could say that a
woman is a man who thinks that he's a
woman it still wouldn't be true
the fact of Womanhood is more
fundamental than the dictionary
the fact of Womanhood cannot be changed
by playing word games and that's what we
need to say
do you think that if you pull out the
dictionary the old dictionary and you
show the Liberals you say no look right
here on the dictionary it says that
that's a woman's not a man that they
will care they don't care
they don't care
there's no there's no argument to be had
there when you're speaking different
languages when you're using language in
ways that are totally divorced from one
another
that camp our answer has to be what is a
woman a woman is a woman
a woman is a woman a woman is the
complement of a man a woman is defined
by the fact that she is not a man but
that she compliments a man a polar bear
is not a man either but a polar bear
doesn't compliment a man but woman and
man are made as complementary beings and
it implies certain roles that implies
certain duties in society and it implies
that men are actually less apt to do
certain things than women are and vice
versa
and implies a whole host of
political and social and biological and
Theological and all these other things
realities
that conservatives don't want to say
stop playing their game stop
playing their stupid little definition
they don't care they don't care about
you pointing to a dictionary and we
shouldn't care when they point to their
fake dictionaries
we just need to say no woman is a woman
you're just wrong okay I'm reminded of
the apocryphal Legend of Saint Nicholas
at the Council of nicaea
and Arius the heresy Arc at nicaea is
denying the Divinity of Christ this all
according to the legend and Saint
Nicholas what does he do
does he does he raise his hand and say
actually you know here's my dictionary
that shows you uh what what the actual
uh divine nature of Christ is no he
stands up and gives Arius a smack across
the face and it's a corrective smack now
I'm not advocating violence okay
but I am advocating a sort of rhetorical
violence or at the very least a a
rhetorical bluntness
when these Libs come to us and they say
well look at the dictionary well
actually my professor said that a man
can be a woman actually you don't
actually there was a study that shows
that the brains of the blah blah blah
whatever just say nah you're wrong
you're wrong a man is a man well what do
you think a woman is I think a woman's a
woman and I think we all know what that
means well well how about you prove it I
bet I don't how about I just treat women
like women and men like men how about
you shut up how about that you know I'm
all for interesting intellectual
scholarly discourse I love it I love it
more than most people
I'm all for debating Big Ideas
but I'm not for Babylon nonsense okay
I'm not for anarchism I'd like there's a
great a great scene of Ronald Reagan he
was giving a speech Ronald Reagan as
warm open-minded a guy as you could
possibly get so polite so chivalrous but
there was some nagging lunatic just
belching out some kind of heckling from
the corner a whole group of these
lunatic students the same sort of people
who today would deny that a woman is a
woman and Ronald Reagan is giving a
speeches well how did you know I'm oh
won't you just shut up that's the that's
just what you say there's no there's no
going there's no winning the debate by
shoving different dictionaries in our
faces a woman's a woman we all know it
and people don't who don't understand
that should just shut up okay
simple as that
it's just crazy crazy behavior reminds
me why the Oxford English Dictionary
chose this word of the year
it's really not just a word it's a
phrase
I had never heard this phrase before
have you heard this phrase before
Goblin mode
Goblin mode which according to online
voters on the Oxford English Dictionary
website
uh what this term means is quote
a type of behavior which is
unapologetically self-indulgent lazy
slovenly or greedy typically in a way
that rejects social norms or
expectations
93 of the votes cast went to Goblin mode
the other finalists were metaverse and
the hashtag I stand with which those are
funny terms too
but 93 voted for Goblin mode and I'm I'm
here for it I totally agree I think that
is the word of the year
and it won because the voters are
recognizing that that actually describes
our society today it's a society that is
unapologetically self-indulgent
we just everything is just me me me me
me me me me and my subjective reality
and my absolute solipsism and and my
lusts and my desires only to be affirmed
constantly by everybody me me me it's a
lazy Society I'm not exempting myself
from this I'm not saying I'm holier than
that I Doom scroll on social media apps
as much as the next person but that's
lazy and it's it's unhealthy slovenly
Society we don't dress anymore
people just wear athleisure
which should be absolutely banned from
society I mean I've
I've owned a pair of sweatpants okay I
understand this is popular but we do it
now in such a way that's so degrading we
just we put on these kind of baritol
brecht you know potato sacks part of
that's because of covid we didn't leave
the home but it's not it's it's
degrading you're a human you're
good-looking people okay dress nicely
we're greedy on the left and the right
the the left is greedian that they want
to steal all your money and the right is
greedy and that they they
exalt or at least in recent decades have
exalted these movies Wall Street the
greed is good all the Iran stuff
everything
and it's in a way that rejects social
norms and expectations everybody's
revolutionary everybody's just such a
hyper individualist we're just going to
do whatever we want Society be damned
our popular art says that institutions
are terrible and corrupting and we need
to reject institutions reject family
reject the social roles that are open
for us
that'll make us happy it doesn't make us
happy happiness and take this
survey for what it's worth these
multiple surveys take them with a grain
of salt but they show happiness
declining
you're seeing life expectancy decline
because deaths of despair
because none of this stuff is good it's
because we're all going into Goblin mode
and when you go into Goblin mode you're
going to look like a goblin but you
don't want to be a goblin you're a man
you're a woman stand up
look look respectable do respectable
things
you won't it won't make you feel good to
be a goblin and this this is a good time
of year to think about it because no
matter how selfish and indulgent and
lazy and degenerate people are
throughout throughout the year
something about Christmas time
brings it into perspective
because at Christmas time we we at least
remember
the virtues and and
charms of family of doing good of giving
to other people of selflessness
of worshiping god of
just being put together in nice and not
so greedy you don't want to be Ebenezer
Scrooge you want to be Bob Cratchit
right
and this is especially at funerals you
go to funerals and all of a sudden
people cry at funerals in part for those
who have died but in part for themselves
as they realize oh shoot I'm going to
die someday
and are people going to be saying you
know here lies Michael he did whatever
he wanted
ah yes Michael Knowles we all loved
Michael so because he didn't care about
anybody and he did exactly what he
wanted all of the time and now he's dead
you don't want people to say that about
you
here lies Michael what a goblin he was
ah he was in Goblin mode his whole life
no don't you don't want to do that
don't Goblin mode is the word of the
Year yes it is it should not be the word
of next year the rest of the show
continues now Mr Davies tells me we have
a magnificent movie trailer that I have
to see I have to focus all my powers
of cultural perception on this to tell
you what this is about you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]